across our many think fast talk smart
episodes a few themes have emerged
repeatedly focus on your audience and
their needs be present in the moment
listen intently be concise and clear the
seeds of these ideas can be heard way
back in our very first episode as we
approach our hundredth we thought it
would be both fun and educational to go
back to episode number one where I chat
with my colleagues friends and
improvisation mentors Dan Klein and Adam
Tobin I especially love when we talk
about being open to offers people make
and being willing to be obvious I invite
you to listen in and learn from this
best of episode of think fast talk smart
the podcast
[Music]
when we think about our communication at
work we tend to focus on our
presentations and meeting contributions
that we know we should spend time
preparing and practicing for but if you
think about it most of our professional
communication is spontaneous in nature
it's providing feedback in the moment
answering questions introducing people
these spur of the moment communication
events can be as important if not even
more important than our planned
high-stakes Communications
for most people these impromptu
situations are quite challenging
I am thrilled to invite two experts and
good friends here today to talk about
how we can become more comfortable and
confident in the spur of the moment
situations
let me start by introducing Adam Tobin
Adam's a senior lecturer in film and
media studies here at Stanford
University and he's a teacher in
continuing studies Dan Klein is also a
lecturer at Stanford both at The
Graduate School of Business as well as
theater and performance studies and Dan
also is an instructor at the Disco
Adam and Dan thanks for being here thank
you thank you glad to be here we all are
involved with situations where the
students we teach or the clients we
coach feel challenged by spontaneous
speaking can you share a little bit
about where you think that challenge
comes from why is this type of speaking
so hard
is a moment when we feel that the
pressure is on it's like everyone's
attention is on us and we have to
perform and the moment we have that
self-conscious awareness it's like our
brain starts to Short Circuit we we go
into a different set of systems we're
thinking about ourselves we're thinking
about how it looks how we did sometimes
we see this in in with improvisers
specifically there's another problem
where if if the pressure's on and you
think you did really well that also
short-circuits your ability to be
present and in the moment and it's
amazing people can shut down or
sometimes people can talk too much yeah
where they can get you know their voice
can get high low it's like their mind
body is running away from them yes doing
everything except kind of what they need
to do in the moment but we are expert at
that because for most of the time we're
improvising you know nobody wakes up and
writes the script of the day and
everyone else goes along with that
script we're actually experts at
improvising it's just when we get put on
the spot and when Adam says we are
experts he doesn't mean me and Adam he
means like Humanity we are experts
that's true that's why I just want to
make sure everyone we're all right and
we see this in in lots of high-steak
situations I think of athletes who who
for years have been practicing what they
do but in that high-stakes situation
that pitched that putt where all the
sudden they they fail or they struggle
because of that over awareness that that
you're talking about
you know before we start getting into
specific tips and and tricks about how
to manage in these situations I really
think a lot of what you guys teach has
to do with mindset and approach would
you guys like to talk about that that
approach that you take one of my
favorite stories is that when I first
moved to the Bay Area before GPS that's
how ancient it was I would go to San
Francisco and every time I would get
lost every single time and it wasn't
until the seventh or eighth time that I
got lost and I looked up and I said I
don't know where I am but I've been lost
here before and if I just make a right
and a right I'll get back on the freeway
and I know how to get home and for me
that was a mindset shift that was I
don't need to have all the answers I
need to be present enough to kind of
find a way to solve the answers you know
I need to be okay enough comfortable
enough being uncomfortable that I can
plug in and our Mentor Patricia Ryan
Madsen who wrote this great book improv
wisdom when I told her that story she
said no no the you've missed the point
the point is to get lost on purpose and
discover what you find and for me that
was another mindset shift I love that
I've I've been trying to run a little
bit more in my life this is I probably
started running after GPS so
um and I find that it's really exciting
to go out and try to get a little bit
lost right I was running near my house
the other day in Oakland and I I was
gonna go the way I know to get home and
I thought I'll just I'll just get a
little bit lost and I turned right and
literally half a block they'd made a
native plants Park in between two
streets it was 10 yards away from where
I was and I had a walk in nature
completely transported and I would have
never had that if my mindset wasn't get
a little bit lost like take the slightly
less traveled path
and in speaking if you're present if you
go just a little bit someplace you
hadn't gone before it may feel
terrifying at first but you're only
going to discover new things that way
that that I think is really the Crux of
of what hinders a lot of people in these
situations is is that ability to let go
there is such pressure to do it right
the expectation is that I've got I've
been asked to do this or I need to do
this and I want to do it right and I
know in your experience and on a lot of
the improvisation that you bring to the
work you do letting go of the getting it
right is really important so can you
share some ideas about how we get out of
our own way there's a wonderful saying
that comes from the world of improv and
I'd love to hear your thoughts on this
but this notion of dare to be dull
and when I I have the audacity to be in
front of my MBA students and say dare to
be dull and it sucks the air right out
of the room because I immediately have
to follow it up with why and and and
would one of you like to help articulate
why daring to be dull is so liberating
it's exactly that it's liberating
because it takes the pressure off we are
so driven to be interesting our Mentor
Patricia Ryan Madsen she had a mentor in
improvisation is Keith Johnstone so he's
like our grand mentor and he he's wise
he said these like our fear of being
seen as unoriginal is one of the most
inhibiting fears that we carry and so
then the idea of like dare to be dull or
be obvious be obvious is the most
powerful creative Mantra that there is
he said when you're trying to be
original you sound like everyone else
trying to be original but when you're
obvious you're yourself and that's
what's genuine if the obvious thing you
say is what everyone else was thinking
then they'll just think you're brilliant
for saying it and if your obvious thing
is different then that's actually
genuinely original
right right and that obvious thing is is
kind of your voice right
um but it's also a it's also true you're
not putting on any kind of fake version
of yourself to try to impress people
you're actually dealing with what's
going on what's in your head what your
reaction to the thing is there's another
message that that we got from Keith
Johnstone and from Patricia that I've
personally found really powerful
and I use it in my teaching all the time
and that is
shoot for average and fail cheerfully
and when I tell students that especially
here at Stanford these high achieving
students I can tell that they don't
really believe it they laugh they
they're sort of guarded and they're
still sort of holding themselves back
but over the course of 10 weeks of
practicing doing this of of doing it
with other people of getting the the
experience of that playful support being
able to fail and have it still work out
I start to see the armor crack I see
them kind of emerge and show up as
themselves which is something that
they'd been holding back there's so much
pressure to be outstanding and original
and and you know break the Paradigm and
yeah the truth is that we can't actually
get to those spaces if we're protecting
ourselves we need to allow ourselves to
play and discover and be authentic I
think those skills can be learned over
time you know you can as Dan said the
more you do it the more you tap into
something kind of true instead of trying
to wow everybody with this false version
I really think this is critical to take
the time to understand how much pressure
we put on ourselves and how much judging
we do of ourselves that gets in the way
of us actually being able to do what it
is we want to do in that notion of
reflecting on what happens if it doesn't
go well accepting the failure really is
liberating
we are certainly not saying that this is
the only way to communicate I all of us
agree there are situations where we need
to do what we traditionally do prepare
plan the wording has to be right
but to have Flex these other muscles and
be able to to have another approach so
we can choose in certain situations to
turn off the evaluation and the judging
enact in another way well in Patricia's
book in the opening she says you know
when I go to a surgeon I certainly want
a surgeon who is prepared and schooled
up and knows what they're doing but I
also want if something goes wrong for
them to be able to be present and
improvise you know also I would like
that surgeon to be able to talk to me
about about what's going on I think if
you get expert enough in your material
then that frees you up to be more
connected more conversational because
you know deep down I know this right you
know sometimes we'll do an exercise
where we'll have somebody tell the story
of their name just some story about
their name first name middle name last
name whatever or tell a story about what
they did this weekend and remind them
that that when you're an expert on the
material you don't have to have every
word perfectly staged if you build a
comfort in your material then you can be
a little more free-flowing and how you
present it being present oriented is
really critical in what I'm hearing us
discuss and and I know a lot of
improvisation requires or invites that
kind of present orientation so I'd like
to hear from each of you a bit about how
prison orientation helps in spontaneous
moments and also let's include in that
this notion of listening many of us in a
q a situation where people are asking us
questions or asking for our feedback
feel that in that moment we are being
challenged that we are that we are being
evaluated and I know attacked in some
cases and I know improv has a lot to say
about this notion of offers and
opportunities do you want to make
mention of that I think that reframing
these situations as a positive then
versus a negative can make a big
difference
yeah I mean one of the improvisers
mantras is that there are always offers
coming at us from all different
directions and that we should notice
those offers so an improviser goes on
stage with absolutely nothing planned
and just the posture of their partner
coming on stage will say ah that person
is just a little slumped or that person
is a little proud and I'll notice that
and I'll treat it as an offer and now
I'll have a sense of what we're
beginning to do on stage so there are
these offers everywhere and our
audiences for sure are giving us offers
all the time yeah when an odd in that
moment when an audience member is
challenging when they ask a question it
might have an aggressive tone to it
something that might put you on the
defensive especially if you're not that
confident about that specific area one
of the things that I learned as a
facilitator I was taught and I've seen
it happen over and over again that
person is the most engaged that's what
they're showing you they are engaged and
they are the best opportunity it's not a
fight you're not going to fight with
them but they're an opportunity so take
that energy get delighted whenever
something goes wrong on the Improv stage
improvisers just get excited they let
they get their eyes light up and they go
oh good what can we do with this it's
live it's an opportunity it's new
information I yeah I am surprised that
that I'm the one that has to say this
but yes and yeah isn't that what it's
all about yeah right so someone
challenging you someone being sort of
negative or or a problem we're instantly
reframing that and I've seen it many
times the person who has the most
challenging question is most likely to
be your Champion they're the one who is
going to be your biggest supporter when
you work with them and are able to
engage and turn around the other thing I
learned was when they ask a question it
has a lot of energy behind it don't
answer say tell me more or say what
thoughts do you have about that like let
them keep talking because sometimes
you're just misinterp putting that
negative energy it's just they're fired
up in another way and the other thing
that's this is a story I tell in the
class that Matt and I teach together
there was a time where I was pitching a
TV show and the person I pitched it to
said to me
tell me why this isn't a Sci-Fi story
and I I thought this isn't a Sci-Fi
story it never occurred to me it has
like maybe there's some element
um and and I said why do you say that
and it turned out that that person's
boss had been burned by the last three
sci-fi stories that they had made what
this person was doing was actually
asking me for ammunition that he could
then take to his boss to sell my story
you know he was solving a problem that I
didn't even know existed and so rather
than seeing that question as an attack
see it as this person is bringing
information from like outside of my
headspace right like I wasn't aware of
this
by bringing that question he's bringing
his concerns and he was actually trying
to help me
what I love so much about that story is
it brings together many of the things we
talked about you you had to be present
in the moment right to to see that
that's what was going on you had to take
the offer that he was giving you and see
it as an offer that there was something
of value there so you really had to be
present you had to listen and have that
money and I did paraphrase I said or I
asked a question back as Dan said you
know tell me more why where is this
coming from and it turned out the deeper
Source was something useful to both of
them I think for folks who are find
themselves in situations where they're
handling objections or taking questions
this advice and guidance is critical you
have to listen you have to be open you
have to see how this is now an
opportunity to expand and extend versus
to just defend and entrench I mean one
thing that was very powerful that I
learned was from you mad which is to
make this into a conversation rather
than a performance and that mindset
shift of I'm presenting I'm in front of
a group but it's much more like I'm in a
conversation where I'm putting
information out you're giving
information back I'm taking that in and
moving it forward and that's a way to
kind of
demystify or take the anxiety out of
these these situations absolutely being
conversational always I think is
beneficial we've talked about a lot of
really interesting useful skills that
people can use to feel more comfortable
speaking in a spontaneous way I'm
curious if if both of you would be
willing to be a little spontaneous we
end each of these podcasts
no not this all right so so indulge me
then I mean yes and yes so I'm going to
ask each of you three questions that we
end each podcast with so we'll alternate
back and forth so and we'll switch who
goes first so you so one of you will
truly be being spontaneous so Dan I'm
going to start with you if you were to
capture the best communication advice
you you've ever received as a five to
seven word presentation slide title what
would it be
Adam already said it earlier I just want
to pull it back in yeah it is not about
you nice very good Adam same question to
you what five to seven words would be on
your slide title that was yours
it's not about you it's about them oh
okay all right credit that's all right
that's all right
a little bit less original yeah we'll
give you the question number two but I
was present and uh
and I failed cheerfully who is the
communicator that you admire and why
you know who I really enjoy is uh is
Trevor Noah the the new um I knew in
years now
um hosted The Daily Show and his
autobiography audiobook is just amazing
but what I like about him is a mix of he
does seem always present he seems always
him you know you really feel his voice
but he can speak
with authority he can speak sometimes
crassly or glibly or sometimes like
really kind of profoundly
um and so I enjoy the range that he
brings and yet it's always him uh so
that authenticity yeah yeah and
specificity and and naturalness yeah I
really enjoy watching him so Dan who's a
communicator that you admire and why I'm
gonna go a little bit obscure here
um almost 20 years ago I went to the
Edinburgh Fringe Festival there's a
British comedian Storyteller named
Daniel kitson who was hosting uh there's
an event called late and live and late
live was Notorious because it was at
midnight and the crowd would be packed
and it was and you get a random
collection of stand-up comics and they
were handling hecklers just pure like
that was the culture of that environment
and Daniel was the host of it and he was
so masterful at playing with what people
would shout out he would disarm them so
easily who's so present
not high status not aggressive very calm
and comfortable but so comfortable in
his own skin and he would name exactly
what was there in the room that's cool
that's cool so usually the third
question that I that I asked asked the
person to give three ingredients that go
into a successful communication recipe
but I'm gonna turn this into a little
bit of an improv game so instead of each
of you telling three let's eat and I'll
play as well say one ingredient that you
would put in the recipe so Adam what's
what's one thing you would put in
cinnamon
no I'm sorry
um uh
how do I say this you build up a trust
in yourself over time and by by putting
yourself out there in safer ways and
then increasingly you get more and more
Comfort I think I think ultimately
having some trust in yourself is is a
really powerful ingredient Dan here's
something we haven't quite talked about
but it fits in Everything plan the talk
be ready have do the research get think
about the audience and their needs but
in the moment when you're delivering use
an opportunity to pay attention like
meet people beforehand in the room have
some quick conversations listen to the
speaker right before you and use
something from the room in your talk you
don't have to change everything you're
going to do but reference something
that's come up on that day in that
moment so that your talk is particular
to that space and that
I like it that this notion of trust
yourself be ready and I would add to
this have fun we put a lot of pressure
on ourselves I'll never forget when I
went for my first martial arts black
belt uh somebody I trust in a mentor
right before I went to do the test he
looked at me and said have fun and I was
in total utter shock how can this just
be fun this is this is something that's
going to be torturous but taking that
approach really made a big difference I
think those three ingredients would make
for a wonderful spontaneous speaker
thank you for that and thank you for
joining today I really hope that people
listening in take to heart the advice
that we gave
it's about the approach you take it's
about having that open mindset being
present listening relying on structure
trusting in yourself taken together
those are the skills that will help
somebody become a better spontaneous
speaker thank you guys thank you
you've just listened to think fast talk
smart a podcast produced by Stanford's
Graduate School of Business for more
information and episodes visit
gsb.stanford.edu or subscribe to our
show wherever you get your podcasts you
can find us on social media at Stanford
GSB